You liked with monster is a big
that was created by a whole bunch of
caricaturists.
But it's interesting that virtually
anybody,
unless they're a professionalist story
and writing about the enlightenment,
anybody throwing out discussions about
the enlightenment,
whether it be Robert Kagan on the right
or,
um,
gee,
I don't know who on the left Fuko on the
left.
Um,
whoever it is,
um,
sees the enlightenment as an isoline
cold being who is sublimated,
Ooh,
passion to reason who believes that
reason is instrumental and calculating
and a matter of technology who has a
blind faith in progress and thinks that
the world is inexhaustibly going forth
for the better.
Uh,
what's,
what are the,
some of the features of the
enlightenment monster?
Um,
those are the crucial ones.
They don't actually fit anyone,
which is why I called them the
enlightenment monster in the book.
Because if you look at the enlightenment
itself,
and you don't need to be a historian and
you don't need to dig into the archives,
all you need to do is read candide,
which was written in 1759 that is in the
middle of the enlightenment by Voltaire.
You see a critique of this very
simplistic enlightenment attitude from
the heart of the enlightenment itself.
That is the enlightenment itself knew
that,
uh,
progress wasn't necessary.
They only thought it was possible.
They knew that other things besides
reason were important.
They spend at least as much time talking
about the emotions as they did about
reason.
Uh,
and they weren't interested in reason
because they were icu or because they
were merely technological,
but because reason was a democratic
instrument against superstition and
authority reason as opposed not to
passion,
but to somebody intuition,
right?
Just as well.
God told me to invade another countries.
So that's a private intuition and
there's no way that I can explain it to
you,
but I just know it.
Um,
it's one way of not using reason.
Another way of not using reason is,
uh,
is to simply use rhetoric to simply use
soundbites,
play the same sound bites over and over
without looking at an entire speech in
context.
Um,
and to create superstition and fear.
And the enlightenment was attempting to
use reason,
which is a faculty we all have,
we can all develop.
Uh,
and we can all debate about,
as I gather you're doing with this
program rather than a appealing to
authority or superstition.
So all of those,
uh,
all of his criticism of the
enlightenment occurred within the
enlightenment itself.
Uh,
the idea,
the other feature of the enlightenment
of course is that people think it was
totally irreverent and anti religious.
It was not irreverent.
It,
most members of the,
there's some who were sheer atheists and
who I even would call irreverent,
lacking a sense of reverence that I do
think is terribly important.
But most of them thought that science
would lead to a greater appreciation of
the glories of creation and gratitude
for the fact that we live in a marvelous
world.
That was how they soil science as,
as a contributing to human progress,
not simply,
although these are important enough
helping to eradicate disease and poverty
and prejudice,
but also in creating a sense of wonder
and gratitude
for enlightenment values.
Because I don't,
we think that there's one,
one of the things that when people
associate something positive with the
enlightenment,
which unfortunately is rare enough these
days,
uh,
they talk about tolerance.
Tolerance is fine as far as it goes.
If you already believe in something,
but it's deeply wimpy,
um,
in the sense that,
uh,
you might conceivably get somebody to
refrain from doing something in the name
of tolerance,
you will have a very hard time getting
them to do anything for something in the
name of tolerance because,
uh,
it's not a value that has a lot of
content.
So instead I've asked that we look at
four different enlightenment values.
One I named two already,
which is reason the other is reverence,
which I also discussed.
Third,
which we've come to take for granted is
happiness.
I think it's very easy for
fundamentalist to look at American
consumerist culture and we've seen a
terrorist do that and say,
you know what?
This is not my idea of the meaning of
life of society that's consumed with,
uh,
whoever dies with the most toys wins as
a bumper sticker in the 90s used to say,
ah,
there's something revolting about that
as a sense of value.
That's not what the enlightenment was
talking about,
about sheer materialism.
The enlightenment was talking about a
right to happiness as distinguished from
whatever fee you got stuck with.
I started my chapter on happiness with
the book of job,
which may seem like a counter intuitive
place to start.
And I started that way because the book
of job is the most read book of the
Bible.
But until the enlightenment,
everyone who read job read him the way
job's friends did that his job had it
coming okay and they went to crazy
lengths to try and construct a story
such that Joe deserve whatever it is
that he got in the enlightenment,
you suddenly began to have a notion that
hey,
actually it would be possible for bad
things to happen to good people and good
things to happen to bad people.
This is not what God has ordained.
And what that means is if bad things
happen to good people,
the world people in the world have a
right to step up and try to change them.
You said before you have that idea if
people were sick,
well you know,
it was probably God's will if people
were poor.
Hey,
that was certainly God's will.
So until you have the idea that
happiness is not something in a last
golden age or something that you might
look forward to in heaven,
but something that if you fundamentally
do what you should do,
you have a right to on earth.
Until you have that idea,
you don't get a sense of justice.
So that's the third enlightenment value.
When the final one is the value of hope,
which is very different from optimism.
Uh,
the people in the enlightenment,
we're not sunny.
They knew how bad things could be.
If you read some of these pieces,
you'll be amazed.
They sounded like they could be written
in the late 20th century.
It's as far as their understanding of
just how dark human beings could be.
So they don't believe that human beings
are perfect.
They just don't believe that they're
committed to original sin.
And interestingly enough,
I think both,
um,
a lot of traditional Christians as well
as a lot of secular postmodernists,
and this is very interesting.
Someone likes Sukkot is actually talking
or he doesn't talk about it of course,
but it's actually giving us as a
foundation and notion of original sin,
what ever one tries to do to improve on
the world is doomed to futility.
Because in fact,
we're all driven by nothing but power
and whatever looks like an alleviation
of injustice is in fact going to be a
refinement of certain techniques of
power.
So when the enlightenment does a way
with those kinds of ideas of original
sin,
I mean,
that's a postmodern return to original
sin.
They're saying,
you know what,
things can get better.
And,
uh,
I think
our own time has seen so many clear
ideas.
So somebody clear examples of ways in
which the world has been changed by
ideals for the better,
but not necessarily.
Torture is a very good example.
If you think about the fact that 300
years ago,
uh,
scenes that would turn your stomach to
read about are things you would have
taken your kids to watch on a Saturday
afternoon,
and you realize,
well,
that was in the heart of civilization.
We've abolished that now,
of course,
as we've seen in the last five years,
this is not necessary progress.
You can turn the clock back.
And one of the things that has to happen
to restore America's moral authority is
for us to take a resoundingly stand
again against torture and for the
enlightenment.
But it is a kind of progress.
It happened.
Uh,
it doesn't happen necessarily,
but it can happen
if we were fortunate.
[inaudible].